durian is of course bashing the Carolina
coast right now after restraining into a
category 3 hurricane its outer bands are
dumping heavy rain as far north as North
Carolina and Virginia hurricane warnings
are up along the coast and more than 1
million people in the Carolinas have
been told to evacuate forecasters now
predict Dorian will make landfall
somewhere in the Carolinas during the
next 24 hours
Tony de copal is in Charleston where
flash flood warnings are in effect with
catastrophic flooding expected Tony what
are the conditions right now there with
you good morning well the rain is coming
in sideways in just a few moments ago
the wind really picked up gusts are now
reaching nearly 70 miles per hour behind
me is the churning Ashley River and
beyond that the barrier islands of South
Carolina they are a shield between where
we are in historic Charleston and what
is right now an angry Atlantic Ocean
yesterday we made it out to those
islands and we found out that residents
more than 50 percent of them planned to
hunker down and right now they are
writing out this storm even as Dorian is
knocking on their front door and as
first responders are unlikely to be able
to respond quickly back here in
Charleston the concern is historic life
threatening flooding
it is expected throughout the next 48
hours and in some parts of the Carolinas
the storm surge could reach 8 feet
evacuation orders cover about eight
hundred and thirty thousand people all
along the South Carolina coast and more
than 1500 of them are right now in about
28 shelters statewide this morning video
I shot yesterday on Foley Beach about 10
miles south of us chose intense winds
whipping away protected sand dunes
that's worrisome this storm could bring
100
it's a one-man out there on Foley Beach
who chose to stay behind to look after
the 40 rental homes he manages what kind
of supplies do you have in there you
know probably eight cases of water eight
pieces of beer good bit of bourbon are
you more worried about the ocean coming
inward or the river coming off but
you'll have six to twelve inches of
water where we're standing right now
I mean we're prepared for whatever
happens that was his mood yesterday
we'll see how he is doing this morning
worried about them out there it's a
folly Beach and the storm surge has gone
past four feet here in Charleston only
two other times in the last 40 years
think about that those were hurricane
Irma in 2017 and Hurricane Hugo back in
1989